what are the next steps for all the
teams how do they actually get it to a
level where it's submitted to the judges
thank you so much Julia and thank you
pepper and
team for putting up the presentation
all right so uh what would be the next
steps so the next steps would be to
complete your project presentation first
of all based on the suggestions and for
the ones who are still waiting for their
pipelines to be processed because of uh
huge data that they have they could wait
for some time and then once they have
their results they update their
presentation and after that they have to
submit it on the omics logic learn
portal
now I'm going to show you how to submit
your project on the portal so you need
to click on your email address that will
uh redirect you to your profile please
make sure that you all have an updated
profile with a profile picture your name
should be in the correct format that is
a title case format and connect your
social media accounts and add a brief
bio
now for each and every coursework that
the hackathon participant has gone
through you might have got some points
that would reflect here in your profile
now as you participated in the hackathon
we would be giving you some Surplus
points that would reach uh that would
take you to a level of 10 000 points and
that will allow you to upload your
project on the portrait now once you
have 10 000 points and your profile is
enabled to upload the project on the
portal you need to click on this
projects option here in your profile
itself and click on start a new project
now when you click on start a new
project you have to fill in the details
that are asked for each and every
section of the project you need to enter
the project Title Here give your project
a specific category obviously it is meta
genomics along with it which type of
microbiome did you work with you can add
that as well as a category and here
under the overview you need to enter the
embed code so when you prepare your
presentation when your final
presentation is ready you need to record
that presentation you can then put that
recording in a Google Drive that
recording has to be in an mp4 file
format you share that recording with me
I'll upload it on a YouTube channel and
share with you our embed code the embed
code will look like this as it is given
here for an example you need to enter
that code here and give a brief
description for your presentation
after that you need to upload your data
set on Harvard University's website data
Awards and how to do that I'll just
redirect you to a course that is course
number nine designing a bioinformatics
project
so for that if on the portal itself you
go to the courses Tab and simply type
course 9 or I'll share this link with
you all as well in this specific
coursework you have the steps mentioned
on how you have to upload your data set
on data worlds in lesson three step five
so you open open lesson three
and you can read through the lesson as
well but I'll just take it to the
specific step where all these steps on
how you have to upload your data set on
data boards are mentioned so here you'll
be told how you have to create an
account first of all and then upload
your data set you copy the link to the
data set and put it back uh in your
project submission you have to put two
links one is the raw data set link and
the another one would be the annotated
data set link now what you could do here
is you can simply put up the runtable
CSC format here under raw data and under
Arrow data data set maybe you can put
the metadata because you prepared that
file from the Run table all right you
gave a brief description about each of
these two data sets raw data set and the
unreated data set and click on next
again you have to and the project
category here so do that next is you
just simply need to enter your abstract
project abstract
enter the introduction of the project
and while entering the introduction and
also by entering the description the
other sections for the images you don't
have to copy paste the images but upload
the images save the images in a specific
folder and from there you upload the
images here if you copy paste it it
might come cracked
the next thing is you upload the
methodology here put each and every step
that you followed uh to reach to your
analysis and then you mention here about
your results
finally you put the discussion to the uh
the interpretation that was made from
the from the results and conclude your
project with the main findings
put the references of the literature
that you reviewed research papers or
review articles whatever you reviewed
and then finally put the acknowledgment
and submit your project now please make
sure that you click on the submit button
submit for review button to understand
the project and close it but save it and
then submit for review as well if the
submit for review button is not working
for you that means you have skipped some
field and some any of the fields is
empty so make sure that all the themes
are filled by you and then you will get
the submit for review option so that was
about how you have yeah thank you let me
just jump in here really quickly
um so this is a uh just the research
portion of your project right so right
here you are going to include
um your data set what you did with the
data set what are your main findings Etc
these are
um kind of like this is the major
evidence for whatever commercial idea
you have and the commercial idea uh can
be separate right it can be relying on
this data set on the evidence that we
found here but the commercial pitch
right is something that
um we will share with the judges and
Link this project as well so that we
know that it is research based so your
translation of the research is the
presentation that you did today with the
backing of this presentation in this
project section just wanted to clarify
that
yes thank you
and once you have your projects on Metro
we will approve your project submission
and your project will then appear under
the project section so if you click on
the project section that comes up in the
main menu you can
signal yeah so when you click on the
project section you can see all the
projects here by our research fellows
and once you submit your project it will
come up as a publication under on this
logic projects as well so this was about
project submission do you have any
questions you can put in the chat or
unmute yourself and ask as well
it's a simple process is it clear to all
of you
and and also I think we will try to
schedule separate one-on-one meetings
with the teams again to make sure that
we can help you as much as possible to
finish this whole process to finish the
presentations and make them look as good
as possible and the recording of the
presentation make as good as possible
because our goal is to really you know
have high quality projects submitted to
the judges so that they're impressed
with you as much as we are impressed
with you because we know how much work
you've put into all of this
all right and uh also apart from the
project submission we wanted to let you
all know once your project has been
submitted and we'll schedule these
one-on-one calls that Elia just
mentioned about and after that we would
also have the session with the judges
where you would be presenting your final
presentation and uh present your page
type basically we will notify you all
about the date whenever it happens so
that you are well prepared in advance
so that was all that I wanted to mention
uh either I would like to add anything
before we end today's session or if the
participants have any question they can
ask
yeah I mean I would just say that
overall this was great you know it was
great to see the progress all of you
have made a lot of progress in your
projects you know it's very impressive I
know that it took some sacrifices on
your part as well so we're impressed and
we hope to see all of the final products
even better than what we saw today so
looking forward to it thank you everyone
thank you India thank you everyone have
a nice day bye